[Music]
there's a battle underway in Washington
over memos Democrats have asked
President Trump to release their memo
it's a rebuttal to the Nunez memo of 10
days ago in the FBI the president says
he will release it but at this point the
memo contains too much classified
information that must be taken out or
altered before the public can see it
some are saying that was the plan all
along the Democrats deliberately created
a memo they knew couldn't be released
congressman Eric Schwaab well represents
the state of California he joins us
tonight congressman thanks coming up
okay great to be back after our
court-ordered cooling-off period exactly
which I was thinking about today and I'm
and I'm glad and grateful that you came
back so ten days ago February 2nd was
the day the new Nance member was
released in and this show had called for
it to be released and because of that
you said that we were working for
Vladimir Putin now the Democrats have a
memo the minority memo and I would like
to see that released and we called for
it to be released on the show as well do
you still think I'm working for Putin
now that I want your memo to be realized
yeah no Tucker I never said that I said
that you're making the same argument
you're on the same side with them but
I'm glad you do with Miranda it was
actually doing his bidding so the
question is is asking for your memo to
be released doing his bidding also yeah
no I said when you're on the same side
you have to ask who's bidding are you
doing but Tucker please answer the
question I'm asking for your you said
that because I wanted new nez's memo to
become public now I would like Adam
Schiff and your memo to become public am
I still on Putin's side it sounds like
it's gonna be a short interview because
you and I both agree the Democratic memo
should be public okay so so the answer
is if I want the Republican a memo to be
released I'm on Putin's side but I don't
want the Democratic memo to be released
on God's side I think both of us agree
that we should get past the memo the
attacks on process and get back to the
evidence in this investigation let's see
when what's so striking though is that
when Nunez was releasing his memo you
guys said and you among them this is
hurting American national security its
subverting the rule of law this memo
that you are trying to release now
apparently has classified information in
it I think you would agree that it does
the Intelligence Agency say that it does
why is that not also hurting American
national security and subverting the
rule
well we did something Tucker that the
Republicans weren't willing to do we
asked the Department of Justice to
review it and if there is anything in
there that would hurt the rule of law or
national security we would want that
redacted but it seems odd that the
president now wants to listen to the FBI
when he was willing to release the memo
before even hearing from them or even
looking at the memo I just was a great
respecter of the FBI and that was the
case you've made for months and anyone
who questions to the FBI is unpatriotic
and they they protect your life even as
you sleep and how dare you question
their judgment are you questioning their
judgment wouldn't you want the FBI to
hold that memo if they believe it in
perils national security we do and we're
working with them right now to make any
reductions necessary but the way the
president has framed this Tucker is very
suspicious I want to know if he's
pressured them at all to hold back any
information from the American people and
I know you say the FBI is subject to
political pressures I thought the FBI
was above politics it's not the case
that you've made night after night on
this show that we shouldn't quote we
should suggest so all of a sudden the
FBI is a political tool but I thought I
was immoral for suggesting that ten days
ago but now you're suggesting is kind of
weird on a political tool oh just said
that you said they had just been
pressuring oh didn't you just say they
do I want to know if he is if he's
pressuring them he can apply pressure
without them being pressured we should
work with them but again Tucker this is
all a distraction it's a charade
actually we really should be hearing
from witnesses because it would be
surprising we haven't heard from a
witness in our investigation and over a
month now I agree and look I mean I
again just to be totally clear I think
that classification is used to shore up
people's power in Washington I think a
lot of things that we should be able to
see we can't because they're classified
for no good reason so I'm very
sympathetic to your case what I'm not
sympathetic to is the changing goal line
here so would you do something it's
great it's in the national interest when
the Republicans do the exact same thing
it's somehow doing the bidding of
Vladimir Putin do you see what I'm
saying no Tucker what what I see is the
FBI said it would be extraordinarily
reckless to release a memo and the
president went ahead and did it anyway
now they have said they have concerns
about ours and what are we doing we're
working
with them we're not going to the House
floor and just reading it recklessly
we're working with them because we still
believe in the rule of law and the
institutions of the Department of
Justice why did you send it to the White
House why didn't you ask the FBI first I
mean you're you're part of the Oversight
Committee you could have asked them
privately hey is there anything in here
you think would imperiled American
national security before you sent it to
the White House but you didn't because
you wanted to grandstand about it
obviously right no it's not
grandstanding it's about an attack that
occurred on our country witnesses in
this investigation now being given
information by the Republicans and us
wanting to follow the rules god forbid
we have a rule of law and a process
that's worked for over two why didn't
you run the the memo by the FBI before
you send it over to the White House
Tucker we've been following the rules
that were given we're in the minority
right now how would be run if we were in
the majority okay we'd be in the middle
of impeachment so really quick look
we've been talking about this for over a
year you've suggested that the president
and the people around him basically sold
out our country to a hostile foreign
power Russia you've prevented and
presented no evidence of that you said
it's either classified or the
investigations ongoing I want to make a
deal live on TV if you have any evidence
that Trump or anyone around him colluded
with Putin to win the election I'll give
you a half an hour of this show live on
Fox big audience and you can present it
I'll let you present the evidence I mean
that because this is going on too much
and I want to know what the evidence is
finally fair yeah yeah fair Tucker but
we're not even looking for collusion
that's the problem on our committee
we're attacking the process we're not
interviewing witnesses if you gave us
time to interview witnesses in the
subpoena power I promise you we could
tell the country once and for all what
happened
it's going on for over a year deal if
you have any evidence at all of
collusion any and I don't care how small
it is I will give the floor to you and I
mean that because I just want to wrap
this up I'm sure you do too a lot of my
conservative friends a lot of my
conservative friends would love to see
be on your show for a half-hour
congressman thank you for joining us I
appreciate it my pleasure